- Well one of the main themes
I have in Only The Strong
is that the decline sensed
by so many Americans
is not an accident,
it's declined by design.
The left has had a plot
to sabotage American power
going back 100 years.
You see that in so many
facets of their actions.
Again, look at what they've
done to weaken the military.
It's almost like birds
migrating south to the winter.
Every time a Democrat
takes office,
he cuts the defense budget.
They've also begun to
distract the military
from its core mission,
which is preparing
for and winning wars,
using all kinds of critical
race theory, indoctrination,
or gender ideology obsessions,
as opposed to focusing
on warfighting.
Or take a look at what they've
done to energy production
in America.
Energy is vital to
our way of life.
It literally powers our economy,
and we are the world's
energy superpower
when it comes to oil
and gas and coal.
Yet Joe Biden and the
Democrats have promised
to eliminate fossil
fuel production in
America, not curb it,
not make it cleaner,
but to eliminate it.
At the same time,
they're dedicated to so-called
green or clean technology.
Who's the world's superpower
when it comes to so-called
green technology?
China.
I mean, they may march under
the banner of climate change,
but the Progressive's
banner looks a lot
like China's five star flag.
These are not accidents.
These are things that
they have done on purpose.
(calming music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me
today is a Senator
from the great
state of Arkansas,
as well as author
of the new book,
Only The Strong:
Reserving the Left's Plot
to Sabotage American Power.
I think you nailed
it with the title.
Senator Tom Cotton, welcome
to The Rubin Report.
- Hey Dave, thanks
for having me on.
It's a real pleasure
and I look forward to
talking to you about
Only The Strong today.
- Well, I've wanted to talk
to you for quite some time,
and basically this
book is a layout
of an awful lot of the
history of the lunacy
that I've been fighting
against on this show.
So first off, what caused
you to write this book?
I mean, you're a Senator,
you're fighting the
madness in DC all the time.
What made you say,
hey, I wanna go
back and and look at
where some of this came from
and and where it's going?
- Well Dave, it all started
last year in the aftermath
of the Afghanistan fiasco.
At first I was astonished
at Joe Biden's bumbling.
Then my team and I spent
a couple weeks in August
trying to do everything we could
to get Arkansans and other
Americans out of Afghanistan.
But as we reflected
on it in the days
after our departure
from Afghanistan,
I had so many people ask,
how could this happen?
How could we lose to a
medieval band of savages?
But it also went
deeper than that,
to things they had
seen in recent years.
Bill and writers
rampaging in our streets
and tearing down
statues of our heroes,
trying to defund the police,
and at least
attacking the police
when they couldn't defund
them as somehow illegitimate.
Calling America systemically
racist and oppressive,
which led to a crime wave
all across our country,
America being a laughing stock
at the hands of our
adversaries around the world.
And at the bottom of all
those questions I thought was,
how did it get to this point?
Why doesn't America win anymore?
And I wanted to lay
out for my readers
exactly how the left in
America has for over 100 years
plotted the sabotage
American power.
Now I'm not claiming that
Liberals and Democrats
are necessarily unAmerican
or they hate our country,
although plenty
are and plenty do,
but at best, they're
ambivalent about America.
They're anguished about our past
and uncertain about our future.
And that's why they've
taken the steps
over the last 100 years
that they have taken
to weaken our military,
to entangle us in a network
of globalist international
institutions,
to bring American
sources of energy offline
while we make ourself
more dependent on China.
All these steps are
part of their effort
to make America just
another country,
a more normal place
that doesn't view itself
as exceptional, or special,
or that has any special
role attributed to it
by God and by our founders.
And I wanted to lay out that
case in Only The Strong,
as well as a roadmap
of the future.
- So before we dive too
much into the specifics
and everything that
you just said there
is exactly what
the book is about.
Since you mentioned Afghanistan
and that was sort of the genesis
of why you decided to do this,
can you talk a little
bit of what it was like
to be a senator the
few days before,
when the withdrawal's
happening, and then after?
Like how much
information did you have?
Did you guys try to push
back on the withdrawal,
at least how it
was done perhaps,
and just were you just ignored,
or were there any
other plans laid out
that wouldn't have been as
messy as what we all saw?
- Yes, a lot of us
did try to explain
that what we saw in August
was likely to happen.
We didn't necessarily predict
the exact timing or fashion,
but the reason why Donald Trump
never withdrew from
Afghanistan in four years,
despite the fact that
he obviously wanted to
was 'cause he was worried that
it would lead to a collapse
of the Afghan government
and a return of the
Taliban to power,
which would impair
America's interest
and threaten Americans
here and abroad.
But Joe Biden came into
office, and he said,
to hell with all that.
Remember in 2009 as I lay
out in Only The Strong,
he had insisted then on cutting
and running immediately.
And as Barack Obama's own
Secretary of Defense, Bob Gates,
said he subjected
President Obama
to something like
Chinese water torture
when everyone else was
trying to get Barack Obama
off the dime to make a
decision on Afghanistan,
to commit the troops necessary
to achieve the strategy
he himself had proclaimed
in the 2008 campaign,
Joe Biden kept
nattering in his ear,
seeding mistrust
with our military,
saying that this mission
could never be accomplished.
And he carried a chip on
his shoulder for 12 years
that Barack Obama
didn't listen to him.
And I think he got
into office in 2021.
And his toxic combination of
incompetence and insecurity
led him to want to think,
want to prove that he
had been right all along,
that Barack Obama
and the Generals,
and all of those
Republicans and Democrats
who had criticized him
for 12 years were wrong.
So in April, 2021 when he said
we're gonna rip the bandaid off,
doesn't matter if the Taliban
has fulfilled the conditions,
that President
Trump set for them
in the withdrawal
agreement from 2020,
we are just gonna get out.
And most perversely of all,
said we're gonna
get out by 9/11,
as if that were
somehow a great way
to honor the sacrifices
and the losses
that we suffered on that day
and on everyday since then.
And as time passed from April
to August, it was clear to me,
partly based on public reports,
partly based on the
intelligence we were receiving
that President Biden had not
taken the steps necessary
to get all Americans out, to
get their family members out,
to get out green card holders,
to get out the loyal Afghans
who had served alongside us,
and they were trending
towards a disaster.
And when people asked me,
how did we see the
scenes from August, 2021
where Afghans were
running onto the tarmac,
they were jumping
onto aircraft wheels
trying to fly out
of the country.
They're handing babies over
the barbed wire topped walls
of the airfield.
It's Joe Biden's
rank incompetence
that caused all that.
We knew this was coming.
He was warned that
it was coming.
He was warned by members
of his own administration,
warned by senior
military officials,
and he simply did
not listen to them.
In fact, just five weeks
before the fall of Afghanistan,
he was saying there
was no way we would see
a scene like we saw
in Saigon in 1975,
had to shamefully take off from
our embassy in helicopters.
That's exactly what we saw,
and it was because of
Joe Biden's weakness.
- What do you think a
clean, effective withdrawal
would've looked like?
So for those of
us that, you know,
it was the longest war
in American history,
in essence, over 20 years.
It was unclear to
a lot of people
why we were there at this point.
Certainly my more
libertarian side
thought we shouldn't
have even been there
in the first place.
But at some point, if you're
gonna wrap these things up,
it seems like it always is
gonna be somewhat messy.
What do you think
a decent withdrawal
actually would've looked like?
- Well, Dave, first I wanna
go back to the beginning
of the Afghan War,
which was almost universally
supported in the Congress
by the American people
since that's the land
from which Osama Bin Laden
and Al-Qaeda had attacked us,
having been given safe
harbor, that's Taliban.
There's no question that we
took a lot of twists and turns
in Afghanistan,
as we did in Iraq
that we shouldn't have taken.
Our main interest in Afghanistan
was to ensure that
it couldn't be used
as a training ground
and launching pad
for further attacks.
Our interest there was not to
try to remake Afghan culture.
It wasn't to try
to improve literacy
or bring economic development.
All those are good things
with Afghan people, certainly,
but it's not in
America's core interest
that those things happen.
So there are many
points along the way
when we should have
taken stock and said,
we're no longer serving our
vital national interest here.
One was in 2009, and
then again in 2011
when Barack Obama
announced a new strategy,
but telegraphed that he
wasn't committed to it.
I'd been there right
before that announcement.
I'd heard a lot from Afghans
about their traditional proverb,
"You have the watches,
but we have the time".
Unfortunately, that
proved to be right.
What a final departure
from Afghanistan
could have looked like and
probably should have looked like
under the circumstances
that President Trump
and later President
Biden inherited,
was ensuring that
there was enough
technical and logistical
support to the Afghan army
to make sure it didn't collapse.
As I write in Only The Strong,
President Biden didn't
just withdraw our troops,
he withdrew the Western
mechanics and contractors
that kept the Afghan
Air Force flying.
These kinds of troops
or even these kind of
civilian contractors,
they're not frontline
trigger pullers,
they're not door kickers,
they're not going out on
raids against the Taliban.
But their presence did
give the Afghan army
a lot of moral support,
a lot of material support
that would've allowed them
perhaps to maintain
conditions across the country
that would've forced the Taliban
to negotiate some kind
of political outcome
as opposed to enable the Taliban
to seize the entire country
in a span of just a
few weeks last summer.
- Do you know if Biden
had anyone in his,
I mean, look, he's probably
not gonna listen to Tom Cotton,
but do you know if he
had anyone in his ear
in the administration
that was going,
hey Joe, this thing is not
going to go as planned.
We're gonna get horrific images,
they're gonna take all our
weapons, et cetera, et cetera.
- He did almost
everyone, frankly.
Certainly his uniform
military leaders,
but also a lot of
his fellow Democrats,
the people he appointed
to high positions.
Look, they wanted to
get out of Afghanistan
just like Donald Trump, just
like Barack Obama before him.
But they also knew the
dangerous consequences
that would follow if we
did what Joe Biden did,
which is simply pull up
stakes without any plan
to keep the country and the
government stable there.
And it's not just Afghanistan.
You saw within weeks of the
withdrawal from Afghanistan,
Vladimir Putin beginning
to marshal troops
on the border of Ukraine.
There's a dangerous
Afghan effect now,
just like there was a
dangerous Vietnam syndrome
after Vietnam
that will reverberate and
harm our country's interest,
at least as long as
Joe Biden's president.
- Do you think that Putin
basically that day was thinking,
all right, this is my move now
because they'll have no
appetite for stopping me?
- Oh, there's no question.
I mean, Joe Biden spent
his first year in office
appeasing Vladimir Putin,
enticing him and tempting
him to a trial of strength
to use Churchill's
famous line that I quote,
in Only The Strong.
You know, when he
came into office,
he granted a extension of
the only arms control treaty
we have left with Russia, with
no concessions whatsoever,
something Donald
Trump refused to do.
That was the first
signal of weakness.
The second signal of
weakness was to allow
the Nord Stream gas
pipeline to go forward.
Again, something that Donald
Trump had refused to do.
Last April when Vladimir
Putin began to build up troops
on Ukraine's border
for the first time,
Joe Biden pleaded to have
a fancy summit in Europe
to elevate Vladimir Putin's
stature internationally.
When you combine all those
along with the Afghan effect,
I think Vladimir Putin saw
the window of opportunity
to achieve what he is
always wanted to achieve,
as I explained in
Only The Strong,
which is to reassemble
a Russian empire,
which starts in Ukraine.
I think Joe Biden's
weakness throughout 2021
tempted Putin to go
for the jugular there,
and now we, and
especially Ukrainians
are living with the
consequences of that weakness.
- You mentioned some
of Biden's motives
and making up for some
of the Obama stuff,
that sort of thing.
How much of what's going on,
generally speaking right now,
whether we're talking
about this withdrawal,
or the economy, or
now Russia, Ukraine,
et cetera, et cetera,
do you think is intentions,
like actually
intended to harm us,
which is partly what you're
talking about in the book,
versus just complete
mismanagement
and hiring of the wrong people?
- Well one of the main themes
I have in Only The Strong
is that the decline sensed
by so many Americans
is not an accident,
it's decline by design.
The left has had a plot
to sabotage American power
going back 100 years.
You see that in so many
facets of their actions.
Again, look at what they've
done to weaken the military.
It's almost like birds
migrating south for the winter.
Every time a Democrat
takes office,
he cuts the defense budget.
They've also begun to
distract the military
from its core mission,
which is preparing
for and winning wars,
using all kinds of critical
race theory, indoctrination,
or gender ideology obsessions
as opposed to focusing
on war fighting.
Or take a look at what they've
done to energy production
in America.
Energy is vital to
our way of life.
It literally powers our economy.
And we are the world's
energy superpower
when it comes to oil
and gas and coal.
Yet Joe Biden and the
Democrats have promised
to eliminate fossil
fuel production in
America, not curb it,
not make it cleaner,
but to eliminate it.
At the same time
they're dedicated
to so-called green
or clean technology.
Who's the world's superpower
when it comes to so-called
green technology?
China.
And they may march under the
banner of climate change,
but the Progressives'
banner looks a lot
like China's five star flag.
These are not accidents,
these are things that
they have done on purpose.
They want to have
$5 a gallon gas.
They want a military
that is not capable
of taking the kind of
assertive, confident action
that Ronald Reagan,
for instance, took.
They want America to be
enmeshed in a globalist network
of international organizations
and one-sided treaties.
That's, again, to get back
to one of the main themes
of Only The Strong,
they're deeply ambivalent
about American power
and America itself.
- So I wanna get into that,
that 100 year march that
got us to all of this.
One other thing on
the international
front specifically,
since we've sort of briefly
discussed Russia and Ukraine,
I mean, do in effect,
are we at war right now?
I know there's been
no war declared,
Congress isn't being
called to discuss it,
but at some point when you are
endlessly funding something,
when you are training troops,
when you are sending weapons,
I mean, what are you and your
colleagues saying about this
at this point?
And should we be calling
Congress to talk about this,
make some sort of declaration
if that's what we're doing?
And what do you think Biden
would do about all that?
I mean, the fact that we're
not even discussing that
seems rather bizarre to me.
- Well, the United
States is not at war,
but we are certainly
supporting Ukraine
and its right to defend
itself and its territory
and its homes.
It's regrettable that
we got to this point,
which we did again because of
Joe Biden's weakness in 2021,
which tempted Vladimir
Putin to do exactly
what he's always wanted do,
frankly, what he
did in 2014 as well
the first time he
invaded Ukraine.
I have to note, as I
do sometimes with my
Democratic friends
in the Senate, which
always sticks in the Craw,
that Vladimir Putin has a
habit of invading Ukraine
when Democrats are presidents,
not when a Republican--
- Somehow there was
a four year blip
where it didn't happen, huh?
- Exactly.
But we are not at war,
nor should we be at war.
I, for instance, agree
with the decision
that we're not gonna
commit American troops
to fight in Ukraine.
I disagree, as I write
in Only The Strong,
that Joe Biden should have
announced that in advance.
It's a bad thing in
a contest of wills
to keep telling your
adversary what you won't do.
It screams hesitancy and
timidity and extreme caution.
By contrast, look
at Ronald Reagan.
Ronald Reagan, almost
his entire presidency
supported Afghan guerillas
against Soviet Russia.
He never considered
putting American troops
on the ground in Afghanistan,
but he also didn't
rule it out publicly,
frankly, didn't say
much at all publicly
about our efforts in
Afghanistan against the Soviets.
That's because he understood
that you don't want to simplify
your adversaries' planning.
You want to keep
them on their toes,
you wanna make them uncertain
about what's gonna happen next.
So while we're not
at war with Ukraine,
nor, or I'm sorry, in Ukraine,
we are standing by Ukrainians
who are simply fighting
for their primordial right
to defend their homes
and their territory.
And we have vital
interest at stake there,
not just in Europe,
but around the world.
For instance, imagine the signal
it would send to Xi Jinping
and the Chinese Communist
if Western efforts
in Ukraine falters
after just eight or nine months,
I think you could expect
them to go for the jugular
in Taiwan very soon after it,
just like Vladimir Putin did
after he saw Joe Biden's
weakness in Afghanistan
last summer.
- I said I was gonna
only ask you one more
on the international thing,
but just extending
that real quick,
I've had Senator Rand
Paul on a few times,
and you know, one of
his big things is,
hey, if we're gonna
give them this money,
which I know he's not thrilled
about in the first place,
but if we're gonna do it, can
we at least get some receipts?
And basically, no, there
seems to be no receipts
to any of this.
What do we do about that?
I mean, because I
think a lot of people,
when they see that, and
another 10 billion here,
meanwhile Florida, you know,
is crushed with this hurricane
and could use some money,
or whatever it might be,
or just give the people
back their money,
I find that that's
one of the things
that people are
really upset about,
that we don't even know who
we're giving the money to.
- Dave, I hear similar views
at home and across the country
on the campaign trail.
I do think we can impose
some tighter controls
on how this aid is being
provided to Ukraine.
I expect a Republican
Congress will.
I think we can also demand
that our European partners
do more to support
Ukraine as well.
Now much of our aid that you
read about in the newspapers
is the inkind value of
the military transfers
that we are making.
A lot of that money in the end
gets spent here in the United
States on high paying jobs
in our defense industry.
Some of our European partners
don't have that kind of
mature defense industry.
They don't have that much
many weapons they can supply.
They should be stepping forward
and providing more of the
direct financial support
to the government in Ukraine,
so it can not just support its
military on the front lines,
but its people as well.
But I do think that we can
have more accountability
for what has
happened in Ukraine,
and certainly what will
happen in the future,
and we can demand a
greater contribution
from our European allies.
- Okay, so let's
back up to something
that you mentioned
about the book earlier.
You said about 100 year march.
And you know, a lot of
people when they ask me,
Dave, when did this crazy
woke leftist progressive
thing happen?
You know, people talk about,
okay, maybe in the '60s,
you know, more communist or
socialist leaning professors
got into the universities,
and that's really
where it started.
But you're really
painting a picture
that began beyond
that Woodrow Wilson,
can you get into some of
the beginnings of this?
- Sure, Dave.
So in Only The Strong,
I explained that much of
modern left wing thinking
goes back to the
progressive era,
specifically Woodrow Wilson,
who was a professor
of political science
before he became president.
You know, for the first 100
years or so of American history,
both parties consistently
appealed to our founders.
They claimed that
they were the one
carrying the true
banner of our founding
of the Declaration of
Independence, our Constitution.
Woodrow Wilson was
the first politician
to explicitly
repudiate our founding
in terms that no
politician today would do.
I mean, Democrats today
certainly will condemn
certain aspects of our founding,
but they always claim to be
living up to its truest calling.
Not Woodrow Wilson.
You can see in his writings,
which were prolific
as a professor,
but he explicitly repudiated
the Declaration of Independence
and the Constitution.
He said that the
Declaration was outmoded,
it was fixed in its own time,
that we all know that
people aren't created equal.
He said the Constitution
was too rigid,
he called it Newtonian,
that it appealed to
the law of gravity
opposed to Darwinian, appealing
to the law of evolution,
and that it was time that
we'd be able to evolve
our system of government
and our way of life.
You know, that's where the term
in legal thinking comes from,
the evolving or
living constitution,
which really just means
the Constitution is dead
because the Constitution
is supposed to be
permanent and fixed based
on our permanent and fixed
human nature.
And that's where our
founders base their politics,
where they base their
foreign policy views as well,
that man is a fallen and sinful
creature, but we can still,
we can still, in the
right kind of system,
built on the right kind
of moral principles,
achieve a degree of freedom
and safety and prosperity
here for unknown in the world.
Woodrow Wilson and
the Progressives
rejected all of this.
This is when you begin to
get the administrative state
with which we're
so familiar today,
but it's really an innovation
only going back about 100 years
when Woodrow Wilson
was president,
he started creating agencies
like the Federal
Trade Commission.
Now you have this entire
alphabet soup of bureaucrats
who were unelected,
yet they presumed to
write regulations for us.
They presume to enforce them,
they presume to
adjudicate disputes
involving those regulations,
which James Madison
said in the Federalist
is the very
definition of tyranny
when you accumulate
legislative, executive,
and judicial power in
a single set of hands.
So you don't get to the
extreme left wing views,
the extreme anti-American views
that you mentioned
until the 1960s,
but it's not a very long
step from repudiating
our Declaration of
Independence, our Constitution,
and our founding principles,
which happen with Woodrow
Wilson and the Progressives
to having outright
rejection of America itself
as I lay out in Only The Strong.
- Yeah, do you think
his full intention
with the deep state or
whatever you wanna call it,
but these bureaucrats
and these departments
that live on forever, well past
the people who founded them,
that that really was
in some ways to subvert
the Declaration of Independence
and the Constitution,
meaning if you could
just staff these people,
these institutions with
enough of your own people,
then actually the
founding documents
wouldn't matter that much?
- Yeah, there's no
question about that,
and it's not even my opinion
or your opinion, Dave.
Woodrow Wilson wrote
about this in his essays,
in his books, he spoke about
it in some of his speeches.
He believed that
our Constitution,
with its systems of federalism,
and separated powers,
and checks and balances was
outmoded for modern times.
It couldn't move fast enough,
it couldn't move
with enough detail.
Instead, he
envisioned a supposed,
a rule by supposed nonpartisan,
neutral scientific experts
who could carefully,
carefully distinguish
all the competing interests,
rise above those interests,
and set the rules
for our society
according to some abstract
notion of right and justice,
as opposed to politics
being a system
that recognizes our
imperfect nature,
that recognizes that
while man's fallen,
nature means the government
has to be able to control,
the government has to
be able, for instance,
to police crime and
ensures civil justice,
that those same
people are gonna be
running the government itself.
The same people running the
government also are fallen
and sinful creatures.
Therefore, the government has
to be able to control itself.
That's why we have
things like federalism,
why we have things like
separation of powers,
why we have things
most importantly, like
regular elections.
All of these things were
innovations at our founding.
They may seem usual now,
but they're innovations
at our founding.
Woodrow Wilson wanted
to get beyond all that.
He had this idea that
there was gonna be
this elite cast of scientific
nonpartisan experts
who would help set the
rules for our society,
and you know, maybe back
then you could have seen,
or you could have thought,
well, this needs to happen.
But after 100 years
of experience with
these bureaucracies,
who thinks that's
the case anymore?
I mean, Tony Fauchi may be
the perfect example to steal
of Woodrow Wilson's ideal
of a neutral, nonpartisan
scientific bureaucrat.
Yet that's anything but
what he has behaved like
over the last year.
Or thinking about
Lois Lerner at the IRS
and the Tea Party controversies.
Or think about Peter Stroke
and Lisa Page at the FBI
trying to take down
the Trump presidency.
Who really has faith
that these bureaucrats,
without any checks,
without any balances,
without any oversights,
are operating for
the public good
as opposed to their
own narrow interest,
or the partisan interests
of the Democratic Party.
- Yeah, it actually
sounds far more
like a dystopian
Philip K. Dick novel
than it does something
that a future president
would eventually write.
When do you think the
Democrats as a party
completely tipped
over into that,
because, you know,
if you think only,
you know, 40 or 50 years,
50 some odd years ago,
JFK as a Democrat asked not
what the country can do for you,
ask what you can
do for the country,
is very reverse of,
oh, just bow to the
state all the time.
When do you think they
actually fully tipped into
what we now see with
the modern Democrats?
- You see it progressing
steadily from Wilson,
through FDR, and Truman,
and then getting to
the '60s, about JFK.
I write a lot about
Kennedy in Only The Strong.
No doubt he was capable
of soaring rhetoric,
but it masked a terrible record.
JFK very much subscribed to
Woodrow Wilson's conception
of the administrative state,
and technocratic expertise.
He had all these so-called
best and brightest
tinkering with the economy,
most especially in the
Department of Defense,
tinkering there, disregarding
the wisdom of the men
who had helped win World War II.
And as I write in
Only The Strong,
you see this most
importantly in Vietnam.
JFK turned Vietnam into
what was a local conflict,
in which we had one
side, South Vietnam,
that was capable of fighting
and defending itself
with our support.
But thanks to his weakness,
thanks to his indecision,
thanks to his belief
in this kind of enlightened
scientific tinkering,
he and LBJ turned the Vietnam
War into an American war
that whose legacy has
distorted the views of America
and turned so many
left wing Democrats
openly hostile against our
country then and since.
- So is there any
Democrat that's left?
I mean, when you're
talking to your colleagues
in the Senate,
I mean, I was a Democrat
for most of my life,
most of my, you know, that's
what put me on the map.
I was a Democrat, I was a lefty,
and I started, you know, seven
or eight years ago saying,
hey, something's not right here.
And then I kind of just followed
that path down the road.
And now when I look at the
modern Democrats, it's like,
man, there is nobody
left that I think
would represent
perhaps a government
that maybe would be a
little bigger than you want,
but not a completely
totalitarian government.
There seems like
there's nobody left.
Are they secretly around?
I mean, do you privately meet
with these people and they go,
boy, the squad's out of
control, but I'm afraid of them.
- Yeah, I wish I
could say I did, Dave.
But no, Democrats are like the
squad members and the House
are fully in the saddle,
responding in many cases
to the large activist base
of the Democratic Party.
I mean, when you
think about Democrats
who believed in a strong,
competent, powerful America,
the last one I can really
think of is Joe Lieberman,
and what happened to him?
The Democrats voted him out
in their own primary in 2006.
People before him who
were somewhat anomalous,
like say Scoop Jackson,
but for a long time
there just hasn't been
many strong Democrats.
Now when it comes time
to go to the polls,
they sometimes might like
to present themselves
as strong or caring
about your concerns.
And the same way Democrats
have been making a lot of noise
over the last couple months,
worried about gas prices,
but it's all a facade.
What they're really
worried about
is their own electoral future,
not about the future of America.
- So if we flash forward this,
I know nobody wants to be
in the prediction game,
especially a sitting Senator,
but if we flash forward this
to the midterms that are,
you know, basically in a week
or 10 days at this point,
I mean, do you sense this red
wave that everyone senses,
and what do you think about
sort of the overconfidence
feeling that, you know,
you got to worry about?
- Well, I believe Republicans
are gonna win control
of the House and the Senate.
I don't wanna hazard a guess
of how many seats we'll have,
but I think most Americans now
are looking at where
their lives are now
versus where they
were two years ago.
They're making less money,
they're spending more money,
their streets are less safe.
We've had 5 million illegal
aliens in our country.
There's a major war in Europe.
China now has a new,
an aggressive dictator
unlike anything
they've had since Mao,
who's shooting
missiles over Taiwan.
And I think they're
very worried about
the future of our country.
And they realize that, again,
this is not an accident,
this is not a mishap.
It all goes directly to the
Democratic Party's choices,
and in many cases, their
intentional desire,
for instance, to see
higher gas prices,
and they wanna check and
balance on Joe Biden.
- Yeah, it's incredible
the intentions part of it.
I'm just so amazed by
that they actually say it
in front of us, you know,
we wanna end fossil fuels,
and then we watch these prices
go up, and then they say,
"But the prices going up
has nothing to do with us.
"It's all because of Putin."
You have to sort of admire that
because then the
media runs' covered.
Does it ever make you jealous
that they have a
whole mainstream media
to run cover for
them, that I would say
doesn't run cover for
guys like you as much?
- Well, we have
reality on our side.
I mean, look, we had inflation
while we had a pandemic,
and we had inflation before
Vladimir Putin invaded Ukraine.
It wasn't caused by
supply chain shortages
brought on by the coronavirus.
It wasn't caused by Vladimir
Putin's invasion of Ukraine.
It was caused by the Democrats
spending trillions of
dollars we don't have.
And as I explained
in Only The Strong,
waging war on America's
energy production.
Those are the two main reasons
we have record high inflation,
and why so many
American families
struggle to make their budgets
meet at the end of the month.
- So what would you want,
I almost said Obama,
who might be
pulling the strings.
What would you want
Biden to do today?
If you sat down with
him today and said,
"Hey, this energy crisis,
we have to fix this."
What would you want
him to do right now?
- Well I write a little bit
about this in Only The Strong,
because it can't
be stressed enough
that energy literally
powers America.
That's why we call it the
power, the power's out,
oh, the power's back on.
That's what makes a
difference in modern life
going back 250 years
is the energy we get from
sources like coal, oil, gas,
and now nuclear power as well.
We have to recognize
that those energy sources
are gonna power America for
the rest of our lifetime.
It is a fantasy to think that
wind power and solar power
is somehow going to
replace those sources.
I mean, we still get
seven-eighth of our energy
from fossil fuels and
nuclear power in America.
And even among so-called
renewable or clean energy,
we get a lot more from
water, and wood, and crops
than we do get from
wind and solar combined.
So as I write in
Only The Strong,
we have to reinvigorate the
fossil fuel industry in America.
Now there's no single thing
that Democrats have done
to strangle fossil fuel
production in America,
so there's no single thing
we can do to help unleash it.
But there's a lot of
steps we can take.
For instance, we can
start building critical
infrastructure,
most importantly new pipelines.
I was in Western Pennsylvania
a couple weeks ago
with Mehmet Oz on
the campaign trail.
We visited a natural gas pad.
There's enough natural gas
in Pennsylvania, and Ohio,
and the rest of America
to essentially replace
all of the energy
that we import in this country.
Yet New England is paying
sometimes quadruple the rates
for natural gas this winter as
the rest of the country does.
Why?
Because New York
won't let pipelines
be built across its territory
to provide American gas
to American citizens.
Think about the LNG,
liquified natural gas
that we could export
to other countries.
Wouldn't it be better if
Europe was relying on America
for American gas, rather
than Russia for Russian gas?
Look at the amount of permitting
that has not occurred
on federal lands,
which is almost 30%
of this entire country
to allow oil and gas
exploration or federal waters.
So there's a lot of
steps we could take
to make sure that the
federal government
is encouraging and
promoting energy production
in this country.
Some of those are also
simply rhetorical,
or even economic.
You know, there are many left
wing banks on Wall Street
that are part of the
Democrats campaign
against fossil fuels in America.
We should be
celebrating the fact
that we have roughnecks
and coal miners
who are helping achieve
energy independence here,
and providing energy to our
allies around the world.
We shouldn't be
trying to cut them off
from access to the credit
and the equity markets.
If we take those steps,
if Biden would simply
appeal to sanity
when it comes to our energy
sources here in America,
we could bring gas prices down,
we could bring your
electricity bills back down,
and we could help rebuild
American power around
the world as well.
- Yeah, unfortunately,
I think I can speak for everyone
watching this right now,
they're going, they just
know he's not gonna do it.
Like it's just not in the cards.
But speaking of
energy and pipelines
and all of these things,
do we have any sense of what
happened to Nord Stream?
I mean, we basically
just don't talk about it.
You know, these, I think
it was four explosions.
We just don't know
what's going on
and we're just letting it be.
- I probably shouldn't
comment, Dave,
on what happened in the
Nord Stream pipeline.
I will say that it never
should have gotten that far
in the first place.
Donald Trump was right
to try to stop it
before it got near conclusion.
And I'm glad that it's not
gonna be brought online.
This is something that
Democratic administrations
before President Trump should
have stopped in its infancy
so it wasn't able to be used
as leverage against the West.
- Got it.
All right, let's shift
a little way from energy
to what seems to be driving
the Progressives of today,
which is the woke
stuff, the gender stuff,
the race stuff, all of that.
I guess that doesn't
surprise you either.
Like that was just
gonna be the next
sort of cultural extension of
the deep state in some sense,
or the administrative state.
- It doesn't surprise me.
Most alarming as I
write in Only The Strong
is it seeping into
our military as well.
This is done largely
at the behest
of the civilian appointees
at the Department of
Defense under Joe Biden.
The idea that there's a
sexist, or racist, or extremist
lurking around every corner,
hiding behind a highly
polished increased veneer,
which is simply not the case.
Our military is exceptional.
They recruit from
a very select group
of young men and women.
You're much safer, and you're
much more likely to be judged
on your merits in our military
than you are, for instance,
at some left wing college
campus in America.
That hasn't stopped down
to the lowest level,
an effort to
indoctrinate our troops
with things like critical race
theory, or gender ideology.
I'll tell you a story that
I tell in Only The Strong
as an example.
A friend of mine with
whom I served recently
became a battalion commander.
So he's in charge of
about 800 to 1,000 troops.
He has to ensure that
his troops all go through
something called the
Healthy Sexuality Briefing.
Now this is a lot more
than what troops got back
in World War II about
the threats of STD
and things like that.
This is all about gender
identity, and transitioning,
and so on and so forth.
And he says that this is
tracked all the way up
to the division headquarters
and presumably submitted
to some higher command
at the Department of Defense.
So he says, "Put
yourself in the shoes
"of one of my company commanders
"who's in charge of
about 125 of my troops."
He knows that he's
got some bureaucrat
up at higher headquarters
looking over his shoulder
to ensure that there's a
little green check mark
next to every soldier's name
on the Healthy
Sexuality Briefing.
He doesn't have
that same bureaucrat
looking over his
shoulder on things
like shoot, move, and
communicate tactical training
at the squad level.
So what is he gonna
take a risk on
in his quarterly training plan?
Is he gonna take a risk on
not achieving 100% briefing
on healthy sexuality,
or is he gonna take a risk
that not all of his troops
will go through the appropriate
kind of tactical training
to have them ready to fight
and win on the battlefield?
I think the question
answers itself.
And now maybe they
won't go to war,
and maybe their lives
won't be put at risk,
because our military
prioritize the wrong things
in training.
But do we really want to gamble
our national security on that?
More to the point, do we wanna
gamble their safety on it?
I suggest not.
All this can end in a stroke,
but it takes a new president,
a new Secretary of Defense
to put an end to it.
- So is that what it would take?
I mean literally, so if we got,
let's say a
Republican president,
we now have a different
Secretary of Defense.
I mean, in essence
you're saying,
you have to fire a
tremendous amount
of the top brass at
the military, right?
- No, I don't think
that's necessary, Dave,
because I mean, the
military is different
from say the
Department of Labor,
or the Department of
Health and Human Services.
There is a chain of command,
and there's an ethos
of moving out when you've
received a lawful order.
And I think it would only
take a new president,
Republican president,
Republican Secretary of Defense,
to say all this ends today.
So for instance, Dave, when I
was in the army, I frequently,
well I shouldn't say frequently,
once every six months,
we had a lot of
mandatory briefings.
You normally set aside a
morning of training for it,
and it was on everything from
equal opportunity policies,
to motorcycle safety,
to personal finances.
And that briefing made
clear, albeit shortly,
that the army is an equal
opportunity organization.
It does not tolerate
any kind of harassment
or discrimination
on the basis of race, or sex,
or religion, or nationality,
or what have you.
And that was that.
And I never saw
anything like that
when I was in the army, Dave.
All it takes is one
Secretary of Defense to say,
"We're going back to the old
ways of reminding our troops
"that this is an equal
employment organization,
"equal opportunity organization,
"and we have zero tolerance
"for any kind of
harassment discrimination."
Here's one PowerPoint slide
that states that policy.
A soldier will get briefed
on that once a year
or once every six months.
And if I find out any
command is using anything
other than this single
statement of policy,
that commander will be removed.
That will end the
nonsense right there,
I promise you.
Because that's what most of
these commanders want to do.
You think my friend, who just
became a battalion commander,
who's achieving the pinnacle
of his professional career,
wants to spend his time on a
healthy sexuality briefing?
No, the vast majority
of officers and
senior enlisted troops
want to focus on
training their troops,
being ready to fight a war.
They don't wanna have to focus
on all these distractions.
- When you're back
home in Arkansas,
and you're talking
to constituents,
and they're seeing
all of this craziness
with the gender stuff,
and we just covered it on my
show where the president is,
you know, sitting
at the White House
with a trans journalist
who's, you know,
and in essence he's
saying that the states
shouldn't have rights
when it comes to whether these
procedures should go through,
I mean, just the
litany of crazy things.
I would suspect in a
place like Arkansas,
there is very little tolerance
for this kind of thing.
- Yeah, Dave, I've learned
over the last 10 years
what I kind of sense growing up
is you can never underestimate
the good decent common sense
of hardworking Arkansans.
And when they hear things
like kids being exposed
to transgender ideology in
kindergarten or second grade,
of doctors performing
double mastectomies
on healthy teenage girls,
or using drugs to block
normal pubescent development
in boys and girls, they
just think it's insane.
Our legislature has
in fact taken action
to stop that kind of
abuse of children,
which I think any decent
civilized society should.
It's one thing when someone
becomes 18 years old
and is an adult and can make
decisions for themselves,
but just like we take
a lot of other steps
to protect children
from fads, and fashions,
and from irresponsible adults,
I think this is a reasonable
step that we take as well
in my state and hopefully
a lot of other states
to protect young children.
- Do you sense
that the direction
that America's going
in where the states
are now feeling very, very
different than each other?
I know you appreciate
federalism,
so, you know, look,
I was in California,
it went off the deep end,
I now live in Florida.
As I tell everyone,
I feel like I live in a
different country actually.
But do you think that this trend
where the red states
seemingly will be more red,
the blue states seemingly
will be more blue,
do you think there's
a danger there
that we will have nothing that
will unite us at some point
if we keep going
down that route?
- Well Dave, I think
the real danger is
more of these liberal
states and cities
trying to impose their
views and their values
on the more Conservative
areas of our country.
Take California and
Arkansas as an example.
I love California.
It is a beautiful state.
It's got a great history,
it's got great people.
I don't agree with much of
the political turn it's taken
over the last 20 years, however.
It's lost a lot of
great people like you
who want to get away
from the higher taxes,
and the regulation, and
the lack of housing,
and the high costs.
At the same time,
I wouldn't presume to set
the laws from California,
from Arkansas.
I wouldn't think
that I get a say,
or that my fellow
Arkansans get a say
in dictating what traditional
state and local matters
to a state like California.
That's not the case the
other way around though.
You know, California,
like other states,
have tried to impose their
views and their values
on other states.
Sometimes they even do things
like adopting travel bans,
saying that California officials
can't travel to a state
like Texas or Arkansas,
unless of course
you're Gavin Newsom,
then you can travel to
places like Idaho and Montana
to go to your multimillion
dollar resort lodges
with your security detail.
But I think federalism
is not just a way
to protect our liberties
as our founding
fathers understood it,
it's also a way to account for
the large continental nation
with a genuine kind of
diversity, economic,
geographic, historic diversity
that allows people
to govern themselves
in the ways best suited
to their environments.
You know, Maine for instance,
is gonna have a lot of
interest and a lot of focus
on the lobster trade.
Not exactly something we spend
a lot of time on in Arkansas.
- Right.
- But then again,
Arkansas has a very
large forester industry,
you know, not again
something that you see
in the great plain states.
These views extend to social
and cultural questions as well.
And I think it's fine for states
to have very
different approaches
to the way their
citizens want to live.
It's not fine when some
of these left wing states
try to then begin
imposing those views
and those values on
more Conservative
areas of the country.
- Yeah, I think that's
the great challenge
we have going forward
is that a certain set of people
are gonna wanna be left alone,
and a certain set of people
won't want 'em to leave alone.
And I don't know how you
arbitrage those two things.
What, just away from the
book for just a moment,
what would you want people
to know about Arkansas
that maybe they don't know?
You know, we talk
a lot about Cali,
now we talk about
Florida, or New York,
or some of the bigger
states or coastal states.
We don't talk about
Arkansas that much.
What should people
know about Arkansas?
- Arkansas is a
great, beautiful state
with wonderful people.
You know, if you don't like
so much heat and humidity
in the summers you
get in Florida,
you should come to Arkansas
where we have four
beautiful seasons.
There's a lot of opportunity
all across the state,
a real rich diversity
across the state.
You know, in Eastern Arkansas
we have some of the most
fertile farmland in the country.
South and West Arkansas has
some of the great timber forests
that we have across the country.
Beautiful mountains, both
the Ozarks and the Washitas,
especially in the
Northwest Arkansas,
there's rapidly growing economy
that has about 1,000 people
moving in every month.
So there's just a lot of
rich and rewarding reasons
to move to Arkansas,
or at least come and
try it out for a visit.
There's no bad time
to come to Arkansas.
We'd welcome you up there, Dave,
just like we'd welcome a lot
of your California refugees
coming in as well,
as long as they don't bring
their politics with them.
- That seems to be the
key to the entire thing.
I basically have to walk
around here with a DeSantis hat
to make sure that my neighbors
aren't freaking out about me.
Senator, I appreciate your time.
The book is Only The Strong,
we'll link to it
right down below,
and I'm gonna be in DC a
little bit after the election
doing some live interviews,
so I have a feeling
you'll be in a good mood
for a couple days after that.
So if you're in DC, maybe
we can connect then.
- Thanks Dave.
Swing by in between your meeting
with all the large number
of new Republican
Senators and Congressmen.
- Sounds like a plan.
Senator Tom Cotton,
thank you very much.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our
Politics Playlists.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our Full Episode Playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.